hey Chris you know what I'm doing right
now what are you doing Sean I'm doing
the sickest well no oh God what I'm
doing the
sickest whe that you've ever seen in
your life you know why that is you know
do you know why that is Chris I'm going
to give you one guess it's Tuesday cuz
it's a Tuesday uh wait oh hi hi I didn't
uh didn't know that we had actually
start are we live on the internet yeah
ah shoot uh hey guys this is uh the Sha
method here on
gamespot.com I'm Shawn mcginness this is
Chris Waters hello uh today we oh no wow
oops I died you are not in a good way uh
so today we are playing playing Grand
Theft Auto 4 for the personal computer
Sean that game came out a dog's age ago
yeah I know I know that game came out in
2008 yeah back when uh George W Bush was
president of these United States of
America days of your that seems like a
million years ago doesn't he had just
been voted out in 2008 right he hadn't
well he wasn't voted out because he was
serving his second term and couldn't run
again cuz that's how the law Works fa in
this country that you live in
for your entire life way to go Chris way
why playing video games with you always
turn on to a Tess and American history
or something uh cuz that's the way it
goes um AP Shan method AP Shan method
that's what's up Grand Theft Auto 4 cool
for the P what's going on why are we
doing this uh a new graphics mod just
came out last week it's called the ice
enhancer 3.0 this is a mod that's been
around for a few years now okay but it's
3.0 now this is 3 0 now so it's the
third one and I thought Grand Theft Auto
4 yes ice enhancer 3.0 yes Synergy the
the Sha method it's perfect it writes
itself it writes itself also I just
wanted an excuse to play another Grand
Theft Auto game on this show it's one of
my favorite series ever they're so fun
and they're so good right okay now
you're just jumping by this dude's what
is this some kind of pickup Bronco
stabbing a truck whoa dude unnecessary
unne NE you like if you stab a truck and
then that truck driver panics and runs
over a pedestrian are you liable for The
Pedestrian injuries I don't know what's
not what's the New York state law he's
hiding in there oh that dude is straight
up hiding he doesn't want he's like he's
not going to see me if I just Crouch
down a little bit over here come on no
he can't if I don't make eye contact
this stabby man will go oh God no he
found me oh no it's my for Bronco oh
this dude needs to dude you're in the
come on listen if someone steals a car
don't stand near to that car cuz that
person's going to want to drive that car
away and you don't know which way
they're going to drive it these are
basic survival laws these people don't
know anything um anyways ice enhancer
3.0 what you'll notice is that it adds a
number of postprocessing effects such as
uh death of field effects enhanced light
Bloom which you can't really see right
now oh wait it's a little dark let's go
check oh look at these God Rays oh
damn look at this I think is cool look
at this
real cool and just generally other
things uh in the postprocessing vein
such as it looks like the apocalypse is
going down oh this whoa what oh that's
the dude whose car I just backed into no
it is oh who you backed into I was going
to say this dude is getting cheeky you
want a piece of this you get stabbed
this is what happens you get stabbed
listen buddy oh oh you're getting shot
you just got shot so badly how are you
still alive I got shot a bunch of times
do you have a cheat codes on I don't no
you're dead
I died again your body is dead also that
pedestrian totally got shot in the gut
that's good cuz by dying it'll pass time
even further and this mod looks best at
night cuz that's when the uh the
lighting effects kind of stand out the
most yeah are you familiar with the term
bokeh bokeh yeah it's when lights in the
background are hella blurry kind of yeah
it's like when a like a normal it's like
you look at a picture of like a
Christmas light and uh if it's way off
in the background it kind of becomes
like a blurry little hexagon that's kind
of what bokeh is sure blurry hexagon but
it's actually not night time it's still
like early evening I don't know anyways
let's just goof around in Grand Theft
Auto 4 for an hour you want to do that
that sounds like a good old
time starting with getting hit by a car
oh are you angry at me what's the
situation lady are you going to walk
away do you understand what kind of
chronic pain I'm going to have do you
understand what I'm holding in my hand
right now what if I just what if I just
drop this what if I just did one of
these yeah you like that oh peace I'm
out of here oh man oh no it got real oh
who's shooting at me I don't know I got
to jump into my America sweet freaking
Hummer holy crap oh no oh that is a
concerned citizen who is trying to blast
you for grenading just general New York
city streets out of my way I think I
dropped a grenade in there
yeah well you got to turn around and
show us the grenade Carnage I saw a fire
hydrant pop off over there oh yeah it's
popping off big time right now isn't it
uh so you know in typical the Sha method
format we don't really have uh any kind
of goals in mind but if you if you're
watching this in the twitch chat and you
want us to do something specific or the
Gamespot chat or in the Gamespot chat
get in there get in there let us know
get let us know uh cuz I just kind of
want to drive around in different areas
and show off this mod cuz it's pretty
cool uh this is a super powerful PC um
and so the mod actually runs pretty well
pretty nice but that being said you do
need a super powerful PC because between
GTA 4 being not a great PC Port mhm and
the mod being a user mod that's not
super well optimized it is pretty
resource intensive so bear that in mind
uh are the cops still after me Chris uh
yes I do see some flashing lights on
your uh y your they're definitely after
you and not caring two shits about the
civilians that they are like power
sliding into yeah that's that's how life
goes typical cops in C I'm going to take
these cops out Liberty City is that what
this place is
called oh my
goodness I mean you did pick a good car
for this oh that wrong place wrong time
buddy you're fine you're fine you're
good get get out run R A don't hold your
gut don't hold your intestines in with
your hands I'll take care of these cops
for you you get running buddy don't
worry you run they won't stop you from
getting to the
hospital these cops are not going to
deny your children having a father oh
did he die I think he fell over I think
he killed over and died he might be dead
Sean where can you download this mod b
Graphics in the twitch chat wants to
know you can go to uh google.com and
search for Ice enhancer
3.0 uh which is what I did it's right
there in the title of the stream so you
should be able to find it no problem and
when I say ice enhancer I actually mean
i c n h n c e r so it's more like is
enhancer I I Canan it's you are
definitely clarifying things for our
viewers you are making it much easier to
understand uh it's actually really easy
to install a lot of a lot of GTA 4 mods
like the really cool like Iron Man
Superman Hulk mods yeah you actually
have to do a fair be fair bit of
tweaking with install files but this
one's really easy you just download it
and you drop a uh I think it's like a
new dll file into the root folder and
it's actually pretty simple when you're
done do you have to say that's the dll
and that's the dll no you have to go
what's the dll with airline food okay
all right we've been trying to escape
these cops for a while and time to like
roll in a fetal position out of the car
going to take cover first of all cover
behind this really insubstantial fence
you're oh God that happened wow that was
a weird lighting effect it's not like uh
the mod isn't perfect you do get kind of
those weird little uh lens FL big yeah
the big circle big clumsy lens flares
that's fine you know you're that's fine
I I died in the Gamespot chat Carlo
relli is ice enhancer veteran saying ice
ice enhancer 1.35 was great yeah yeah
all right apparently we need the HD Road
textures though I can't remember if I
installed those or not I don't don't
know if I did I know that I installed
the vegetation
textures I think vegetation I know that
at one point I thought about installing
the vet let's look at some vegetation
then here man I mean that tree looks
nice that bark is pretty on point I
don't know you don't dig it is this
that's like well I don't know maybe not
okay so now I'm I'm trying to Showcase
like a good example of what the mod does
well you'll notice that so I think it
actually I could be wrong suffused in
the glowing light of dusk oh it's so
lovely correct me if I'm wrong but I
think this mod actually like improves uh
the draw distances in the game as well
does that mean you can snipe someone all
the way at the end of this street I
don't know let's find out actually I'm
going to let's put that away I want to
show you one thing that I loved about
Grand Theft Auto 4 that was not included
in Grand Theft Auto 5 do you want to see
what that is I would love to okay uh now
Grand Theft out of five a great game
great game one of my very favorite games
of last year but there is one particular
feature that it did not contain that
made me very very sad first thing I need
to do is that why you were so sad for
like the last eight months all right
here we go see this guy
yeah see how see how knock the coffee
cup out of his hands you want this
coffee take the coffee you missed his
head real bad head I'm going to get him
come on you got to get him all right oh
wait did he disappear he disappeared ah
[__] he's one of the disappears you want
this coffee you want this coffee he's
wearing what looks to be a water
resistant jacket oh don't you check your
phone at me take a he is totally
unperturbed by the maniac throwing
coffee
around all right you want this coffee
he's coming back for more you want that
caffeine get him take the caffeine oh
yeah oh what an impact got the extra
wall slam and he's coming after you he
has put up his Dukes this dude wants to
fight well little does he
know oh I missed him
here's what I'll do just give him a
little stab just a light stab oh come on
come back look you gave him a light stab
right no I didn't I'm all right I'm just
going to give him a light just a light
prick just a little pin prick yeah just
just prick him like that and then that's
fine and then one of these just Boop
real quick Boop he's standing there we
go there we go hold in your insides and
flee hold them in and now I'm going to
hop after you like a weird bunny
and then maybe just like a real quick
there we go oh not getting away oh he's
F CRA hold in your inside R you better
run wow this guy is having a bad day
he's having a situation this went real
bad for him and you're just like slowly
walking after him like total Maniac yeah
cuz I want to make sure that he gets to
safety I'm not a monster Chris what do
you I don't want you to just pass out
and bleed out in this alley man yeah why
don't you just uh head into this alley
body likes to have a little stabby
stabby bang bang fun once in a while and
uh I just you know no one needs to get
hurt pick up that soda can you pick up
that garbage you think I can mail from
way down here from downtown from
downtown Oh no just short I can get him
though I believe in you uh well can you
get him while the cop is going to shoot
your face oh no you ain't getting my
coffee you ain't getting my coffee
that's not coffee that's a straight up
32 o big go today coppers me and my big
gulp are getting out of here
peace getting out all right a
conveniently empty taxi van let's just
hop in
here excuse me cops you are in a bad
place right now Sean what do you think
about the uh observation by Altier
assassin that you are a
sociopath I mean that's a legitimate
claim I I there certainly you could
build a case You' seen me play video
games well okay so the what's the
difference between a sociopath and a
psychopath a sociopath does not
empathize with other people right is
that the difference whereas a psychopath
is just like balls out crazy I'm going
to look it up online dictionary like a a
sociopath just doesn't feel human
emotions they're just cold and awful so
like Sherlock would be a sociopath
Sherlock is a high functioning sociopath
in the modern Incarnation BBC Sherlock
yes exactly um this is a Sicky
motorcycle and I'm going to steal it
well uh these these definitions on
Mariam Webster are pretty similar uh
sociopath someone who behaves in a
dangerous or violent way towards other
people and does not feel guilty about
such Behavior okay psychopath is a
person who is mentally ill who does not
care about other people and who is
usually dangerous or violent so the real
difference is with psychopath there's
mental illness implied and sociopath is
not but
H I'm I'm a little sketchy so sociopath
is just kind of like a
blanket doesn't care about other people
whereas a psychopath but it's also
violent towards them so a psychopath
might care about other people it's just
they don't have any way of controlling
it cuz they're crazy they're cray cray
is that how it works Bruce Leroy says
you guys might want to check the
graphics settings in your options menu
because it doesn't look like that much
of an upgrade all right let's check take
a look let's have a
look show me Graphics here go so this is
what we've got it looks like you have it
on Max Graphics I have it on maximum
Graphics
definition off on off on vehicle
density 100 you just turned it to one
you have one vehicle density I have what
does that even mean I have an amount
aspect ratio you have a single vehicle
density
hi hi this is all with the ice enhancer
3.0 uh but also if you guys are watching
on Twitch you might be getting a
slightly compressed version of the
stream as sort of all twitch streams are
so I mean it's it's it's a mod that
works a lot better in screenshots than
it does in motion because when you are
like you fix your view on an object like
this motorcycle a dope whip yeah and
then that's like when the other things
in the distance kind of fall victim to
the depth of field like that little
Archway in the back there or let's see
what is this thing so like wow you are
mean mugging there Nico oh yeah I'm
straight mugging homie uh so there you
go that's your buddy Nico B you were
having a bad day you were in like a real
intense kind of mindset maybe you
shouldn't have drank all that coffee
yeah that coffee really did uh really
did a number on my
insides um
so so you can kind of see it like it
flickers like that building in the
background kind of like flickers in and
out of focus depending on how we like P
well if if Nico turns around then it
comes back into Focus it's not a perfect
mod you know it is a user mod it's not
it doesn't have quite as much polish as
a professionally developed but also if
if you're looking at this and comparing
it to the most recent GTA you've seen
GTA 5 it's not a fair comparison cuz GTA
5 looked really good compared to GTA 4
GTA 4 does not stand the test of time
super well visually and this mod goes a
long way towards making it do that also
time to ride a helicopter oh I really
thought I was going to going to get that
guy knock that guy in there let's try
that one more time all right yeah okay
we're going to do this okay we're going
to do this it's good to have goals it's
good yeah life goals are
important please you can do it what if I
just just clock him no I will not form a
line yeah you think I'm going to get in
line peace I'm taking one of your
helicopters these security officers are
concerned about you
causing yeah you guys want a piece of
this you can't catch me I'm rich and I'm
crazy come on come on try to get me try
to get me I'm crazy and I don't give a
[__]
you think you're going to get me this is
GTA 4 in a nutshell oh yeah that's right
here's waiting for you to tie yourself
out boom boom boom slash slash slash
slash slash slash let that be a lesson
to you if a dude just starts circling
you sprinting around and around maybe uh
don't antagonize him with punches to the
face like that he might have a knife oh
right in the dick boom right in the
right in the dick also the butt it's
time to get out of here oh this guy
piecing out they're like ah we got to
get out of here
man you trying to shotgun a chopper yeah
all right exactly what I'm trying to do
that really didn't work did it wait hold
on uhoh I got this show me that draw
distance I don't think this is going to
happen I think they going to disappear
oh it's gone after them all right here
we go we're going to catch those guys
but first no
Witnesses oh sorry
Jesus oh just got him in the thigh but
he's sprinting off at alarming rate for
just having taken a bullet to the femur
oh he is making run for it oh gosh this
is going to be easy pickings should I or
should I just let him live damn it oh no
he changed his mind he's like I can't
swim with this FAL walk off he's going
to walk it off wow he's a new man after
this guy's a trooper this guy's a real
Troop Trooper he is a champ he is Big
Time champ oh no he disappeared wow see
that's Grand Theft Auto 4 is a video
game that is uh has you know some bugs
some bugs oh oh where' you come from
this is
cute I think you should Land The Chopper
on the Copper's head I should do that
excuse me my
friend I'm going to have to borrow this
from you and your friends listen guys oh
please don't kill me Chopper or copper
copper Chopper oh
just drop it right on
him come on do you remember to how to
fly a chopper good you do oh good job oh
GG everybody is this also a cop
fantastic is there ALS no oh I don't
think so that person just hit the deck I
don't know if you hit them he hey we're
good we're good we're good we're good
who wants to take a helicopter tour oh
I'm a maniac and I'm trying to fly a
helicopter what up come
oh I was just trying to chop him up a
littleit wow you really did that let's
go to the beach let's see if anybody's
suntanning on the beach yeah let's go
man need a little
relaxation to uh man I missed the uh
soundtrack to GTA 4 so good yeah they
got good Tunes in this game here we go
we're over at con that person is waving
at you I think is this also a cop no he
wants a ride oh this dude thinks that
he's going to go for just like a
Pleasant Run on the beach oh me uhoh
you're doing the chopper
thing whoa whoa did his body just go
flying whoa oh no okay oh my blad broke
Chopper what's a chopper without a top
rotor okay a weird looking bus it's like
a shitty car it's a shitty car it's just
a shitty car it doesn't even have wheels
on it's like a sled is all it is it's a
big honking sled yeah hey hey there
person did you see some weird helicopter
action on this
beach do you know where I can find a new
helicopter don't you talk on that phone
around me oh nice Waldo beanie let's see
where she goes I think she's making a
run for is she going to run into the sea
she's the it looked like she was going
to the safe Embrace of Poseidon but then
she thought differently entirely
possible this beach is deserted yeah it
is I bet this is a super fun site a
super fun site yeah it's like look wait
hold on did you say super fun or super
fun super fun okay with a d yeah with a
d d at the end you guys know what super
fun sites are they're places that uh are
like too saturated with toxic ways to
like be inhabited by people and really
need to be cleaned up and they created a
super fund to do that and that's why
they call them super fund sites but it's
really misleading yeah because it sounds
like super fun but really it's poison
how about we go some vodka I feel like
the soccer fields I play on might be on
a super fun site are you calling Roman
to go boozing we're gonna go get going
go get a load
on you think you can pick him up with a
commercial airliner hell yeah well I
wish I had my
helicopter all right we're going to pick
up Roman then we're going to go get
lit I should probably put away the
rocket launcher and the grenade but I
will keep the knife out in case things
go sideways in case some dudes are doing
a shady deal on the beach no drug deals
no drug deals stop selling drugs drug
people don't you dare try to do drugs on
my beach listen this is my beach I'm
cleaning up the streets you get out
peace a the old stab and run the oldest
trick in the book Robo keeps asking for
this swing set glitch the swing set what
is the swing set glitch Robo in the
twitch chat describe the swing set
glitch glitch to us and we shall attempt
it oh no I might die before I can go
pick up Roman this dude is really angry
at me for stabbing him is he shooting
you or is he just trying punching me I
lost a lot I lost a lot of Health in the
uh getting blasted in the face by a cop
while you're trying to steal helicop
that and there was the crash and oh
no wow nice move oh yeah go pick up
Roman on a freaking scooter all right
don't worry see you later don't worry I
know how to evade the police in this
game the trick is to drive away from
them until they forget that you
exist and that's precisely what I'm
going to do right now their object
permanence is pretty poor they're like a
little baby they have really bad object
permanence oh no the cops can see me I'm
going to have to go through this alley
we're making a break for it Chris who
are these turs now this is definitely a
drug deal oh man that guy just wanted to
buy some meth no drug no drugs in my
city scooter of Justice Rides Again here
comes the scooter of
Justice should we do the sweet cinematic
camera again yes
obviously oh making a break for it
scooter of
Justin I'm a
boss doing sick
wheelies uh this is the The Cinematic
camera that you can slow down I don't
know if you guys remember that part w oh
oh no you just did a freaking triple
Luts boom Oh you get that was incredible
that was a pretty sick Landing that was
freaking great I'm not going to lie to
you that was dope as hell we're going to
go pick up Roman and go get
a go get a just be careful because Ricky
guitarist says I took a date on this
game in a motorcycle I hit a truck and
she went flying into the ocean and then
she stopped returning my calls is it cuz
she was dead in the ocean I think it
might have been I think that is probably
the the thing that happened to your date
is that she died in the
ocean if I mean if I had to guess I
would say that's probably that sounds
like a real plausible Theory all right
Roman I got a I got some friends with me
they're they're the police I got the
cops and a scooter that we could go get
a little drinky drink he's not going to
want to party all right
Roman okay you need to find a car let's
see I suggest the road like this moped
that I just stole hop on Roman yeah oh
yeah let's go get lit the
cousins cousins right again we might
need to hide in this alley for just like
a little bit of time don't you need to
get outside of the radius yeah you're
right drive a motorcycle into a swing
set and you fly across the map what woo
oh my goodness you are an incredible
Stunt Driver on this SC I have a talent
I I played a lot of Grand Theft outo
four when it came out all right oh this
cop might see me get not spotted by the
cops for a little bit so you can get lit
all right we're good
cool uh I once met the voice actor who
plays Nico bellik yeah at Comic Con
2008 2009 I think it was ComiCon 2008
okay what did did you get lit with him
no it was in the uh the celebrity
autograph area which is the most
depressing place in the world have you
ever been there it's just a bunch of
tables with people sitting at them yes
and uh there are a small handful of very
popular celebrities with big lines of
people you're passing a bar right now
and then
Chris forgotten ones like Johnny Drama
like Johnny Drama and the voice actor
who played niik Bellic he just trampled
Roman come on Roman you were a freaking
Maniac yeah it was a little it was a
little sad it made me depressed but then
I got over it cuz I'm a resilient man
you are and we're going to go get lit go
inside of this real shady looking bar
and get
pissed all right Roman what is that
shirt here we are also your shirt has a
lot of blood on it here we are is this
not where we can I get any bottle
service wait no this is a this is a
drinking place we're playing darts oh
we're not playing
darts yeah nice throw nailed a six seven
how do I skip darts how do I skip darts
I didn't mean to do darts
oh D power darts oh je I'm going to do
speed darting oh that's so much darts I
just wanted to get
drunk Chris is this too much to ask skip
oh my goodness Roman is kicking your ass
at darts 195 points
remaining yeah it's real bad just let it
happen Roman is going to beat
you there we go go okay now let's get
drunk
Roman uh should I play again you should
press lb to
quit I forget how you do the the
drinking where's the freaking bartender
where's the bartender I don't know man
it's time for you to take over this
establishment all right what do you want
what do you have buying don't just oh
he's going in the is that I have my
knife out is that the problem yeah maybe
no one feels like they should serve you
because you're a stab of
maniac kind of true listen it has the
martini logo on it but there's no
bartender I don't think it's going to
happen how do I do you remember how to
get drunk GTA
4 no excuse me my friends I straight up
do not should we go to the other bar I
feel like this is kind of a [__] dude
bar this bar sucks this is a real this
is why you can't get drunk here you need
to go to a classy bar no you got to get
off this island oh we got to get out of
yeah you got to go to Manhattan yeah
that's where the players you need to
roll up on your scooter to that bar all
right Roman with me we're going to go
get drone Roman we ride now we ride
Roman here we go I won't do wheelies
because I respect my virtual cousin's
life what do you think the chances are
that we're going to get there Alive by
the way I think uh it's pretty
slim pong Ley says there's a marker
outside by the first tree perhaps
referring to drink I don't know but
we're already away all right go go go go
go gadget homicidal maniac
cousins honk honk honk oh
lady what got to watch out lady you
think that was my fault that was
definitely not my fault all right Dan
has given us instructions on how to do
the swing glitch okay we'll do that next
first we have to go get drunk first
we're getting
drunk and then we're going to go to ban
all right done and
done out of the way
folks oh there goes that idea okay why
did I shoot that car wow oh that was
good that was good wasn't it yeah it
turns out the chances of us making it to
that establishment were zero don't bet
on Sean surviving what come all right
you need to find a car that can
withstand much damage a great example
would be the
taxi do it the taxi is one of the most
resilient vehicles in the game I don't
know if you've oh look Roman is uh is
happy with me oh really he had a good
time dying in a car crash give me the
old thumbs up let's see which car should
I
steal lady you want to know what I think
of your
car that's what I think of your car F
your ride [__] your ride in fact I'll
take this looks like a sensible car all
right where am I going all right you got
to go to the Firefly projects is one
spot so go look no all right here I'll
let me point this is where the map says
on I zoom in with the
trigger map says it's right oh yeah yeah
I know where that is press a boom go
there done go to
there no
Witnesses
what apparently pong Le was talking
about the psychopath miname when he was
talking when he or she was talking about
the marker outside the first
tree press X to scrape your cousin's
face on the sidewalk yikes who oh check
this
out oh [__] wow oh that was a twofer
that was good you think he's still alive
oh oh he's he right he's fine I'll get
this guy
ready rear Endo turning him around he's
still on his bike what a champ ladies
and gentlemen that dude is uh that a
boss listen you don't you don't get on a
scooter in Liberty City unless you're
ready to deal with
some
rubbing Bruce Leroy 76 says try
trilinear Textures in your graphics
options try linear textures all right is
that an
option
TR linear all right let's do it let's
get TR linear up in this apply yeah
yes all right checking out TR linear
textures oh man thanks to bruer Leroy in
the gam spot chat what do we
think where's the
swings are you at the Waypoint I'm at
the Waypoint all right we're going to
find these swings and then uh do some
Maniac stuff we'll be right back after
this quick break
and we are back yeah uh we're just
trying to evade the cops real quick so
that we can do that uh glitch a little
bit more easily uh as long as okay we're
good you're fine you're clear go back to
the playground back remember where it is
to the playground excuse
me was that dude angry at me go to the
playground Focus okay all right fine
fine fine
fine here we go back to which way is
it
we're going to go
here
here all right so according to Wiki how
yeah drive your car and park it near the
legs of the swing and keep accelerating
backwards ooh the direction you're
facing is the way you will be catapulted
from also make sure you're as close to
the leg as you can or it won't work if
you did this correctly the car will have
conflicts with with the swing EG
shimmying moving and the game will tell
the swing to forcefully push the car out
of the way because the swing is attached
to the
ground
oh come on come
on oh
y all
right no go you got it yeah all right
Herculean
effort where are the swings those are
there the
swing [__] that was tight as hell oh
look at my car your car is so caved in
it is yeah excuse me folks just going to
drive along here bless you rob shoe
Don't Mind If I Do let's try that again
that was tight actually I feel like we
got to we got to get Roman we messed up
with the Roman situation
earlier
it's good
drinking are you going to get drunk and
try that
again that was good that was good that
was good cousin glitches man they make
the world go around you know that's true
especially Grand Theft Auto glitches for
they are truly the greatest of glitches
oh I think he turned me down that makes
me angry that makes me want to do one of
these
no
no just rub yourself up on a
taxi tax some car humping is that what
you're doing right
now
oh ow up and over ow that hurt all right
you may
proceed Boop let's get out of
here did you just leave I just dropped a
grenade that's your favorite move the
cash grenade drop casual real casual
grenade drop I got to say woo going
bowling for Bros bowling for Bros bro
bowling I got to say yeah people in
Liberty City are real astute at like
spotting when a grenade hits the floor I
feel like I would not notice it I feel
like someone just drop their
iPhone and then I would blow up oh hello
coppers woo wo wo wo woo there's a
little present for you
enjoy these guys have not figured it out
there he goes to their Peril oh one of
those dudes survived it you're about to
die look at that stupid gun you have
what it's a cool dude gun I really wish
it would be nighttime so I can we can
see the nighttime lighting effects but
you know sometimes it's just hard to
survive for more than 3 minutes at a
time when you have the attention span of
a four-year-old and a sociopathic
nature oh hard out there for a sha I
should call Brucey that's what I'm going
to do that's what shake and Sparco in
the Gamespot chat has suggested just now
right let's call up Brucey phone book
Brucey drinking dear Brucey can we do a
drinking please what's up man drink hey
Nikki you think I'm a [__] [__] not
calling me for so long that ain't cool
not again man not again to hard bodies
like on
the you hurt his feelings a little bit
but now you're going to go out on the
town with
him all right
Brucey what are we going to do with
Brucey oh brucey's real close by oh
we're going to go drinking we're going
to get drunk we going to actually get
drunk this time yeah and then we're
going to go drunk driving you were
pretty terrible at drinking last time
yeah I could let's see if Sean can
string two goals together all right so
far you've been able to acquire one if
we're lucky where are the vehicles Chris
it's night time everyone goes to sleep
and parks in the ample parking provided
in Liberty City there is ample parking
that is
true and that's the most unrealistic
thing about the game oh excuse me my
friend
oh it's fine I forgive you I'm a man who
exercises the art of forgiveness excuse
me oh you are no no no oh we're
good Brucey I wonder how he's going to
feel about the fact that I brought got a
friend oh
no ah you're
loss oh no no no no really it was that
guy's loss we could have been hanging
out could have been he could have met a
compelling
and cool guy Bruce super like a super
cool guy yeah real cool guy here we go
we're going to just whoop whoop zip zip
zip around this corner and yep there we
go
you ever been to this part of Brooklyn
Dumbo yeah man I hung out with Brucey
why you calling it Dumbo though Dumbo
that's what it's called in uh in real
life down under the Manhattan Brooklyn
overpass really
yeah I went to a wedding in dumbo one
time it was pretty tight were there any
elephants there there were surprisingly
few elephants okay so I feel like
wedding without an elephant man I mean
come on is this when we actually get to
see like the
graphics can we see
Graphics not really getting such good
Reflections on this car kind of a little
bit there oh whatever show me the
graphics Sean you can see the graphics
right now we're going to go pick up
Brucey and we're going to get
tanked what up
Brucey get in the car we're going to go
get drunk
let's get the [__] out of here homeboy
wow rude let's go to this place Rude
Dude with a
toue here we
go let me ask you what are your personal
goals oh man you're going to get a pep
talk from the
Bruce whatever s confused pal all right
drive drive respectably I don't want to
die you might learn something is bruy
driving no that's not a
thing AI doesn't drive you I drive if
you're in the car you're driving that's
the ni Bellic
way
everything beanbag Samurai wonders if
Brucey can swim but first we're going to
figure out if he can drink yeah we're
going to find out we're staying on task
here we're staying focused we're going
to accomplish something in this world
godamn it the car is only slightly
smoking so that's a good sign we might
make it that's a good start you're
getting close also now when you get
there try
not to totally f everything up my best
can you please I'm going to do my best
oh
look park it in front of the
booze let's have a drink then we're
going to do this so that's what I missed
last time was the little yellow marker
on the outside mhm all right Brucey hop
in we're going to go driving our cars on
fire we are super
drunk white alond I'll be okay did you
oh are you going to eat oh no I don't
want to diner you are going to sober up
man no don't sober up oh no we're still
drunk are you oh yeah you're a little
bit drunk a little drunk why don't you
get in that hummer that's a Brucey
mobile that is a Brucey
mobile yeah you are definitely driving
like a drunk ass
boss like we need to do more drinking
you think we can do more
drinking no probably not are there any
more bars way either way we're going to
drive bruy into the ocean that's let's
see if bruy can swim yeah do you think
bruy can swim let's take bets all
right can Brucey
swim will he
survive the trip into the ocean we're
not even it doesn't even look like
you're going straight into the deep end
here it looks like you're going to drive
like gently into the O into the waves
wow after doing a nose grind definitely
a little right now you are just doing
sweet Donuts on this beach all right
here we go taking Brucey into the drink
Stan Pines thinks he
cannot peace oops those there come on we
had rocks there that is rocks Brucey in
the car in the car buddy man get in the
car get in the car so I can drive you
directly into this twinkling
ocean will you just go in literally
you're steering away from the ocean will
you just drive into the freaking ocean
it's I'm doing my best in almost every
direction from you right now all right
here we
go sorry Brucey okay you are good we
have yet to acquire bruy bruy I see it I
see some some waves I see some SP Bru I
think he's coming oh my goodness he is
an accomplished swimmer Bruce is we got
ourselves a drunk Michael Phelps over
here look at this guy he's fine he's
back for
more good work Brucey good work buddy
just a congratulatory knife stab now
just walk away like just a little stab
don't just like all right we're still
going to hang out right Brucey I'm I'm
bored of you I need you to go away from
me Brucey he's hanging out Brucey he is
bruy all up on you I need you to get
away wow you made his groin
explode ruy why are you still following
me this date is
over can't you take a hint come on you
get out of here Brucey oh my
God all right he's he's feeling pretty
come on Bru murdered bruy you get he's
not doing very well go home bruy he's in
the fetal position I don't think you
guys are friends anymore you're standing
upon him like a hunter mounting his
trophy we're good we're good Bruce's
doing fine brucey's fine don't worry
about
Brucey you come on Brucey I like how you
put your foot up on him like you just
defeated him in WWE wrestling yeah oh
get come on Brucey did you let him get
back
up get out of here Brucey go go go boy
go come on get run away maybe you need
to call him on the phone and text just
text him GTFO GTFO Brucey I need you to
get the hell out of here wow Brucey is
very
resilient get all right just stand there
we're just gonna how long can you stand
on him oh he keeps standing
up oh now I injured my friend now he
doesn't like me the 17th stab is what
did it stabs one through 16 were fine
games they say the 17th Cut is the
Deepest yeah oh no now the cops are
coming after me did he disappear I got
to get out of here is Brucey no mo
Brucey uh well I injured him you can't
actually kill uh The Story characters
but did he disappear oh I don't know is
he still ring around on the beach over
there oh maybe we we got to hide from
the law Chris I've got more important is
there reason you're running directly
towards the law in order to hide from
them that's a good question allow me to
answer it with my my
M4 shot through the heart did those
bullets look like they bounced off that
dude a little bit
huh that dude is
alive he's not alive anymore yeah little
little target practice
here oh you going to have to reload
anyone
here
okay we're good we're getting out of
here time this situation just got a
little bit too heated very considerate
of them to
bring the Sweet Rides yeah you should
turn this beach into a demolition derby
should I I don't know should I do that I
feel like there's not enough rides to
make a demolition see I feel like here
all right now you can see it see see how
the building is like out of focus whoa
It's so out of focus that's NextGen
lighting right there Chris uh see you
see that all it took was zooming in on
this Bullet Hole on the back of my
police
car I I like the water you like the
water the twinkle of the lights upon the
Water oh yeah that's nice isn't it legit
yeah it's pretty pretty boss all right
we're going to get away from these this
is definitely a road that you can drive
on so long
coppers this party they're shooting you
from a helicopter you should go in that
tunnel should I go in this tunnel you
should hang I feel like there's homeless
dudes okay in there
obviously but the homeless dudes won't
try to shoot you
probably psych it's not a
tunnel it's just an arch here we go and
these cops think they're going to come
after me they got they got something can
you see the helicopter they got a
surprise happen maybe you should shoot
the
helicopter yeah I should there it is all
right oh you ready is it going to hover
ready this is going to be a tough shot
and wait I got to anticipate it
movements yep oh it's turning around
this is perfect
time nope oh yeah you missed it oh I
missed it yeah the RPG do you like how
kind of just casually he doesn't even
look he just goes
Boop you blind firing an RPG I'm blind
firing an RPG that's how it's done he
just holds it sideways out a this this
gun near uh I don't know okay cool there
we go
that's what I want to see I missed him
no you got him oh I dropped my RPG and I
died I
died oh oh Sean all right we got we got
10 minutes left what's what are we going
to do chat if you guys have any last
suggestions just let us know just let us
know you know what I kind of want to do
what Y no the top of the Empire State
Building okay should we do that getting
up top yeah getting up top
okay all right uh it's taking a little
while to
load taking a little bit of time to load
it's leaving you time to think about
your actions that's it's very true you
maniac now you know where the Empire
State Building is I believe it's here I
believe this is the Empire State
Building are you going to try
to fly onto the top of it or like take
some sort of elevator you have to take
an elevator but there is a shortcut uh
Diablo lurker wants you to go
bowling other people are suggesting the
swings I think you should Rob this lady
of her
beater sorry lady this is what you get
for not washing your
car treat your automobile with respect
and maybe it won't get stolen from you
and you get run over by it that was a
love tap she's fine see that she's okay
she is definitely fine oh maybe not that
time I mean you hit her under another
car there's blood seem to be slow to be
getting a lot of blood do you think she
think I think she's still
alive but she's just kind of playing
Pome yep she's riding and now she's out
of focus too yeah cuz we're looking at
this sweet pole yeah sweet pole while a
blurry lady tries to broken
ribs that's the least I could do I'll be
he wants you to pick him up because you
stabbed him 17 times
together all right going to go pick up
my buddy Brucey from the hospital he is
just at the place that I was at a minute
ago all right Brucey let's come get you
we're going to restore you to safety
shaken Sparco says it's also fun to take
a fir truck drive it into the subway
park it sideways as two Subways approach
from opposite directions cuz the game
freaks out that seems like a good idea
of a thing to do they're also saying
take Brucey for a ride on the
swings should we take Brucey for a ride
on the swings I feel like that's a good
way to welcome him out of the hospital
yeah all right here we go it's like look
all right the Empire State Building can
wait Brucey has to
fly bruy needs to know what it's like to
really
live oh I love bruy such a good
character so repressed hot Duck Soup in
the twitch chat is asking which version
are we using and can we provide links we
are using which version of The Mod or
the game the mod uh we are using the 3.0
version MH for
steam uh and uh we can provide links yes
I'll let you do that cuz you have a
laptop sure I'm gonna let Dan do that
because I can't be
bothered classic
Chris always go into the extra mile make
it
happen I mean it's right here I I think
on this dude's
uh yeah I think I found it let's try
this yeah limb found it boom
limore AK only one of those characters
is actually in limb's name but thanks
for putting the link in there oh come on
I'll put in the game there we go all
right so I back into it is that what I
do uh drive into it just kind of drive
into the swing area hey whoa cross town
oh he off the water tower stuck on the
fire escape uh How You Like Me Now
Brucey Brucey I'm sorry I know that you
just got out of the hospital and all but
we are in a situation we uh we got to go
cinematic camera for this this is a
cinematic camera situation if you're
plus oh you guys are screed we got to
get out of here you are stuck in there
oh no a news Chopper footage coming in a
car landed on the eighth story fire
escape know what we're going to have to
do right P Chuck a grenade right out
here oh God going to see if that takes
care of
us yo it took care of you it did and are
you burning yeah you're are we dead this
is the weirdest crime scene ever oh yeah
can we save that clip you gads that was
like a skill shot man that was a good
one that was pretty good that you
bounced off the Water Tower and fell
down that is a great glitch do you think
that you can jump out of the car while
it's in the air I don't feel like we
should try that one more one more yeah
okay I'm down one more also do you think
I can find a
prostitute I don't know Sean do you have
sin in your
heart have you been watching this
show so that's a resounding yes and I
need you to get out of
this scorpion says it really was a fire
escape
L okay I'll take it I'll take it hello I
like it I really all right keep keep an
eye out for any uh any
prostitutes you don't know how many
times I've heard Sean say that keep an
eye out I got money burning a hole in my
we'll just go to Subway for lunch and
he'll say that on the way yeah keep an
eye out for any prostitutes we were like
is this guy a prostitute we were like
getting ready before your wedding and
you're like keep an eye out for any
prostitutes I can't have them around I
can't have them I can't have them are
you a prostitute will you have sex with
me and also fly into the air for money
for money that's sorry Salient Point
here I will pay you I will pay you money
come on man money dollars listen are you
a are you a there's a jump I don't think
that random pedestrian is a prostitute
this guy a prostitute well you have sex
with me for money
fine fine the thing is like I know
exactly where to find prostitutes in
this game but it's far away it's over in
uh prostitute Valley yeah prostitute
Valley I don't know if you've ever been
to prostitute Valley but once you
enter you you can't exit it just costs
money to you just have to pay for
everything yeah you just pay money after
you get your hand job B Tampa sea says
to The Prostitute you want to take a
ride on my swing set
all right doesn't look like I'm going to
find any ladies of the night around here
what about these dumpster kids are you
uh no these are clucking Bell employees
you guys want to you want you want to
ride my listen I know you're making
minimum
wage in at the clucking Bell your car
looks pretty nice the lighting on this
car oh yeah and the reflecting see that
you can see the graphics mod sometimes
you can you can I encourage you guys to
check it out if you have GTA 5 on the PC
and I I feel like if you compare this
mod to like the just the vanilla version
we probably should have done that but
it's not so easy to switch between the
two on the Fly uh but actually it does
look it does look quite nice show enough
even if it's you know it's not the most
polished thing in the
world Sean yes swing set to the swing
set to the swing set all right we're
going to end the stream with me
launching off the swing set and then
jumping out of the car in midair oh
right right can't forget to jump out of
the car in
midair you did I mean nothing's going to
top your car carwise nothing's going to
top parking it on the fire escape yeah
that was pretty boss that was like the
most skilled parallel parking you could
possibly do is this just a like a
regular lady or a prostitute no just a
regular lady I don't know I think she
just got alarmed by your fender bender
with Johnny suitman over there Johnny
suitman Bob suitman all right you're
you're like really close to the
playground
and can make it there and some
cops all right no prostitutes that's
unfortunate can find prostitutes at
139th and fourth a says goob Sho Riot
that's very specific
goob thank you for your help I
appreciate
it h pong Le in the Gamespot chat making
the uh key observation that the cluck
and Bell person probably didn't have
health insurance so good job whoops that
one's on me guys that one is on me all
right this is it we're going to try to
do some swing set Shenanigans to close
out the Sha method come
on swing set oh my
god wow oh that was rich that was weird
that was good and delightful weird and
delightful that should be the tagline
for this show weird and delightful yeah
I feel like sociopathic gameplaying just
doesn't have good SE juice uh no no it
does not so that was uh the uh Grand
Theft Auto 4 for the PC with the ice
enhancer 3.0 mod just Google it you'll
find it it's really easy to install um
and thank you to jam kaani for
developing this mod I'm not sure if I
pronounced your name right but we had
fun with it we did have fun it was cool
we did yes and it was cool Chris what's
coming up on the lobby the lobby today
we're going to be digging into some last
of Us
remastered uh taking a look at that
talking about the last of us and also in
light of the sort of uh dramatic reading
they did last night of the The Last of
Us script they had the actors up there
uh performing it which was pretty cool
and uh yeah we're going to talk a little
bit more about that Mega Man helmet
giveaway I think and see some highlights
from ComicCon if you guys missed our
live shows this weekend come on by the
lobby see some Comic-Con fun goodness
also Kevin vanord is going to be playing
Firefall game that's been in beta for
quite some time but I believe is
officially releasing for
reals official officially oh sorry I was
uh totally not randomly shooting people
in GTA you really are that was
definitely not a thing this wasn't me
this wasn't me that that was already
there plausible other explanation for
that she ran into a tree so did that
Fender not even damaged this guy ran
into a tree that's that's I that's not
blood that's a that's a slurpie that's a
slurpie that's a slurpie situation this
cop has wants to have some words with
you that cop ran into a
tree Miss he ran into a tree he he
walked into a door trees are the city's
greatest Menace he walked into a door it
was my fault when my fault come on back
in two hours for the lobby and uh more
fun times here at Gamespot thanks for
watching Sean see you guys later you
going to get murdered here uh probably
probably going to get murdered such as
life such as
life